[Musique]
c'est une exposition qui rassemble des
artistes femmes des années 20 qui ont
vécu ou qui ont travaillé à paris elles
sont venus de tous les pays du monde et
de tous les continents pour se former et
pour rejoindre toutes les avant-gardes
parisienne paris c'est la capitale des
arts dans les années 20 plus que new
york plus que berlin c'est aussi la
seule ville du monde on n'enferme pas
les homosexuels dont il ya aussi une
grande liberté de vivre ses préférences
sexuelles et puis c'est une ville où se
croisent tout le monde que ce soit les
romanciers les peintres les sculpteurs
l'émergence d'un cinéma expérimental est
évidemment de toutes les stars du music
hall paris est une ville on s'amuse on
invente et où les femmes et les hommes
se croisent dans les cafés
[Musique]
la chambre bleue pour moi ça a été
l'origine de cette exposition suzanne
valadon se saisit d'un des stéréotypes
de la peinture l'odalisque c'est une
femme couchée la plupart du temps nu qui
a été essentiellement peintes par des
hommes mais cette femme elle est couchée
et elle fume la cigarette et là c'est
vraiment le signe de la femme moderne
autre signe très important il ya des
livres à la place de l'habituel le
bouquet de fleurs qui décorent les
odalisques peintes par des hommes donc
on est ici vraiment dans une invention
du regard féminin sur le corps féminin
une revendication de la modernité de la
femme
les tableaux américain pique nique de
juliette roche on a vraiment choisi de
terminer l'exposition dans la dernière
salle avec ce grand tableau grand format
et en fait résume un peu cette cette
période cette décennie ce un peu l'âge
d'or en reviennent un peu dans un
période où l'artiste montre comment les
hommes et les femmes peuvent cohabiter
en paix et en harmonie ensemble au
milieu au centre il ya donc un pique
nique il ya trois personnages avec trois
différentes couleurs dépôt donc aussi ça
les regarde les autres
la diversité ce qu'on appelle le jury la
diversité tout est assez un pays il ya
bien évidemment aussi un clin d'oeil à
la danse de matisse il y a sur la droite
un autoportrait de l'artiste même qui
nous regardent donc il ya un clin d'oeil
et bien évidemment aussi à l'histoire de
la peinture avec l'artiste qui regardent
les visiteurs donc c'est un peu en
résumé de cette décennie et de cette
période folle
qui étaient les années 20 à paris